what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and it looks like we have some new
information about Doctor Strange 3 and
how exactly this is going to directly
build up to Avengers Secret Wars now for
those of you who were a little bit
disappointed with Doctor Strange and the
Multiverse of Madness I gotta say based
off of what we've heard so far in this
report about what Doctor Strange 3 is
going to be about this movie sounds like
it's going to be absolutely amazing and
if you enjoyed Multiverse Madness you
should enjoy this one even more we knew
Doctor Strange was already going to have
a pretty big role not just in Avengers
King Dynasty and Avengers Secret Wars
but in the Multiverse Saga in general
and it looks like we were absolutely
right he's going to have a huge role to
play and doctor strange 3 is going to be
an extremely important film going into
the Kang Dynasty and Secret Wars however
he's not exactly going to be viewed as a
good person or a hero by some people
based off of the post-credits scene for
Doctor Strange and the Multiverse of
Madness we know that incursions are
happening and Doctor Strange himself has
caused one this is why Clea showed up at
the end told him he caused one and said
that they're going to fix it then
seemingly cut a hole in reality into the
dark dimension and Doctor Strange was
ready to go well as it turns out we
might know exactly what CLIA is doing
and who she is working with but we know
she went to get Doctor Strange because
he caused an incursion but this isn't
the only incursion that a doctor strange
has caused because we learned in
Multiverse of Madness from the
Illuminati that the variant of Doctor
Strange in the 838 Universe also caused
an incursion so so far we know that two
different variants of Doctor Strange
have caused two different incursions and
this is going to be a really big factor
in Doctor Strange 3 as a new group is
now going to be looking for Doctor
Strange and the Multiverse has already
begun to fall apart we'll break down
everything you need to know in this
video and if you're new be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest MCU news and if you
subscribe and leave a comment you're
automatically entered in our giveaway
for a chance to win an Xbox series X A
PS5 some Marvel Legends items or some DC
items as well the winner gets to pick
one item we pick a winner at the end of
each month so this report today comes
from thecosmiccircus.com in an article
written by Alex Perez they say that they
know what Doctor Strange 3 is going to
be about and that they're going to be
adapting the time Runs Out Marvel story
now we'll go into details about this
story but one thing that's really
important to note is that this story
time runs out when it ends it
immediately goes into Avengers Secret
Wars the 2015 version so this is pretty
much a direct Prelude into Secret Wars
which I believe is going to be very
similar in the MCU Doctor Strange 3 is
going to build up either right into
Secret Wars or right into Avengers King
Dynasty and the way everything is being
set up right now this story to be
portrayed in Doctor Strange 3 sounds
fantastic in the article they State
according to our sources Marvel Studios
wants to adapt elements from the time
Runs Out comic event for Doctor Strange
3. the film would pick up right where we
left off and Doctor Strange range in the
Multiverse of Madness where CLIA
traveled From Another Dimension to seek
out Doctor Strange for his Aid in fixing
the incursion that he personally caused
the article continues to state from what
we've been told strange has been sought
out by a multiversal organization called
the black priests according to our
sources CLIA is a member of this
organization the black priest's HQ will
be in the nothing space of destroyed
universes which exists within the space
of two dead universes caused by an
incursion it will be revealed in the
film that the Multiverse is dying the
cause of this Decay is a result of the
incursions happening all across the
Multiverse the most recent being the one
caused by Doctor Strange the film will
also elaborate on a point made in the
previous movie regarding doctor strange
and his threat to the Multiverse and
this is where it looks like strange is
going to get into a little bit of
trouble the article continues to State
it was made clear in the previous film
through Christine Palmer 838's research
that Stephen Strange is one of the most
dangerous threats to the Multiverse
however they have yet to specify how
exactly he was dangerous outside of what
Doctor Strange 838 did the upcoming
sequel will explain how Steven is a
threat to the Multiverse by establishing
him as a common denominator when it
comes to incursions Across The
Multiverse aside from the main danger of
the Council of Kings and the final thing
they state is while it will be confirmed
that the main reason for the decay of
the Multiverse is due to incursions
being caused by the Council of Kings it
is unknown at the time if the film will
feature a king variant or if the film
will flat out confirm with the source of
that decay is however our sources told
us that the film will serve as a direct
preamble to the upcoming Avengers film
so it looks like this will go right into
Avengers the King Dynasty which makes
perfect sense now let me explain what
time Runs Out is in the comics it is
kind of where we're at in the MCU which
is why this fits perfectly and there are
multiple different teams and there are
even Multiverse reversal teams in this
storyline when you dive into the comic
incursions are already happening again
this goes right into Avengers Secret
Wars in the comics incursions are
happening and the Multiverse is dying
however there is Big conflict between a
lot of the heroes for example there are
two different Avengers teams there's
Captain America leading his Avengers
team which is under Shield's Authority
there is another Avengers team which is
sunspots own Avengers team and then
there is the Illuminati in which Captain
America's Avengers team is fighting but
even though they're fighting they are
still dealing with the threat that the
Multiverse could be destroyed at any
given moment at one point in time in the
comics they reveal that while there were
over hundreds of thousands of earths and
universes there are now only about two
dozen left only about 24 left and Earth
does not have that much more time and
there are multiple Earths in this comic
that they jump back and forth from but
in the comics they actually do run into
the group The Black priests but in the
comics the group is actually led by
Doctor Strange himself so big
connections here if CLIA seeks to find
Dr strange and Clea is a part of the
black priests that could mean Doctor
Strange is going to get heavily involved
and is going to help fix the incursions
or they're going to Simply turn on him
and try to just keep him out of the way
since he seems to be at the cause of a
lot of incursions him and his other
variants of course but of course since
he's going to appear in the gang Dynasty
and of course Secret Wars we know that
he'll either end up getting away or
he'll probably end up the leader of the
organization in the comics the black
priests are trying to stop the
destruction of the Multiverse they are
trying to stop incursions and that's
exactly what doctor strange and Clea set
off to do but there is something really
really cool that does happen in this
comic it's eventually revealed that the
beyonders are behind everything they are
the bad guys and what's interesting is
they even managed to kill the cosmic
entity
eternity once eternity is killed the
Living Tribunal comes in but then the
beyonders killed the Living Tribunal
this is really cool because we actually
saw the Living Tribunal in the last
Doctor Strange film when they were
traveling through different universes we
saw a few different living tribunals
plus not to mention in the very first
movie mordo mentioned that he had the
staff of the Living Tribunal we were
introduced to Eternity in Thor love and
thunder and now it looks like the cosmic
entities might be making their way to
the MCU in a more prominent way we were
introduced to the celestials and the
eternals and then we saw them again in
Thor love and thunder and what's really
interesting is that the beyonders in
this comic story go around to different
universes killing off the celestials
that would be why eternity and then
eventually The Living Tribunal step in
to interfere however the beyonders
defeat them and here's how Doctor
Strange I think will tie into the King
Dynasty and ultimately will result in
the destruction of maybe our own Earth
and the Multiverse because in this comic
storyline time Runs Out The Avengers do
not win they are not successful at
stopping all of the incursions what they
end up doing is making Escape pods and
they make them out of the Living
Tribunal the remnants of his body which
they called the Lifeboat and basically
their plan was to take all of the heroes
and flee Earth be the other Earth the
Ultimate Universe Earth was about to run
into their Earth causing the destruction
of both of their planets so the last
plan the last option was to Simply leave
to be able to live and maybe one day
reverse what had happened but many
Avengers die in this process Captain
America Tony Stark they both end up
getting crushed by the other Earth that
runs into their Earth Thor and Hyperion
die to the beyonders and eventually the
incursion does happen and we go into
Avengers Secret Wars which is exactly
what I believe is going to be happening
with the King Dynasty I believe Doctor
Strange 3 is going to really amplify the
threats of incursions happening and I
believe that we are going to start to
find out that our particular Earth Earth
616 is in Jeopardy of an incursion so
this will start the group The Black
priest trying to prevent it alongside
with Doctor Strange however we do know
that the Kang Dynasty is kind of going
to be like Avengers Infinity war and
Avengers Secret Wars is kind of going to
be like Avengers endgame so I am fully
Expecting The Avengers to lose an
Avengers King Dynasty and what we could
end up seeing happening is something
very similar with the time Runs Out
story The incursions happen it's done
there's nothing they can do and they
simply flee they flee Earth and then
what I believe will happen after that is
the remnants of all of the different
universes will come together The
Avengers from one Universe the
Illuminati From Another Universe the
X-Men From Another Universe will all
come together and figure out a way to
defeat King the Conqueror and reverse
the incursions that had happened now in
the comics this is basically done by the
Fantastic Four Reed Richards and the son
Franklin Richards so I bet Reed Richards
is going to have a pretty large part in
secret Wars but he also might be
revealed in Doctor Strange 3. we know
the Fantastic Four movie is coming and
supposed to be coming before Avengers
King Dynasty which means it should come
before Doctor Strange 3 as well and
Doctor Strange already learned in
Multiverse of Madness that read Richards
knew a lot about the Multiverse and
incursion so it would make sense that he
would try to find the Reed Richards of
his own Earth his own universe and seek
his help if it's not in Doctor Strange 3
it's probably in the King Dynasty either
way I know he's going to be running and
to read Richards at some point in time
but if Doctor Strange 3 really is
adapting the time Runs Out storyline
from the comics that means that
incursions are about to be a much bigger
threat than we've seen so far and I
believe Earth our main Earth 616 is
about to be in big danger as well and if
we think about it it makes sense Doctor
Strange has Multiverse jumped a lot we
do have the Scarlet Witch in our
universe and she has dream walked and
severely affected other universes and
these are the types of things that Mr
Fantastic said cause incursions so
Doctor Strange being at the center of
incursion sounds about right and it
looks like that's what Doctor Strange 3
is really going to be about so let us
know your thoughts about this in the
comments down below I think this sounds
like it's going to be a fantastic movie
but let us know what you think please
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe and of course you can always
follow us on Instagram and Twitter as
well as always thank you all so much for
watching wolf wolf